the pandemic has shown the limitations  of  some of our old ways of working  but it has also created new ones in  record time  so take the vaccine that will hopefully  protect us  all from covet 19.  what normally takes 5 to 10 years  to develop a vaccine was achieved in  10 months because the world  pooled its resources scientists  shared their expertise and different  manufacturer worked together  the european union and others helped  with money  large sums were invested to build  research capacities  and production facilities early  europe invested billions to help develop  the world's first covered 19 vaccines  to create a truly global common good  and now the companies must deliver  they must honor their obligations  and this is why we will set up a vaccine  expert transparency mechanism  europe is determined to contribute to  this global  common good but it also means business  you